let's say you've got a a Shopify store
that sells coffee mugs and you spend
$11,000 a month and you make $3,000 back
so the constraint of the system at some
point will either be I run out of mugs
it could be that I just need to spend
more money because that might be the
constraint today and then I spend enough
that I run out of mugs or I spend enough
that my cost per impression exceeds my
profit because I go to colder and colder
audiences so then the constraint there
might be like I need to build a brand or
I need to get trusted sources to
increase the awareness let more people
know about my stuff so that when they do
see my ad they're more likely to make
the purchase it's really being able to
accurately identify what the contraint
is